I want to share a story with you that um
really had me cracking up when I was
reading it this morning you guys may
know about Fox News host Maria Bartiromo
I've talked about her before and for me
one of the most interesting things about
Maria Bartiromo who now is just a total
pro-trump propagandist on Fox News and
Fox Business is that she used to be a
really good reporter when I was in my
teens and started following the stock
market and casually getting into trading
stocks and whatnot I would watch CNBC I
thought I was cool watching CNBC and
Maria Bartiromo would be on there and
she'd be reporting from the floor of the
New York Stock Exchange first woman to
do so doing really good interviews with
CEOs holding people accountable asking
tough questions and she was really a
very interesting journalist and reporter
and over the last few years either
because of something that happened
mentally or because she really liked the
idea of being in Trump's good graces and
having direct access to a president or
whatever she became an uncontrolled
unflinching pro-trump brown-nosing
sycophant and it turns out that it's not
just a character that she plays on the
air there is there are new Revelations
from this upcoming Jonathan Carl book
we've told you about the book already
and there are many interesting
revelations in it that she actually
spoke to Donald Trump's former Attorney
General William Barr on the phone and
went nuts on him about supposed voter
fraud committed by democrats to steal
the election from Donald Trump she
really seems to believe this stuff I
want to read through um some of the
allegations outlined here new book
alleges foxes Maria Bartiromo shouted at
Bill Barr about imagined voter fraud
this is crazy these are crazy
allegations former Attorney General Bill
Barr says Fox News host Maria Bartiromo
called him up screaming about imaginary
voter fraud according to his account in
a new book betrayal by Abc's Chief
Washington correspondent John Carl
highlights barter Romo's damaging role
as promoter of Reckless lies about the
election in the book book which comes
out today
Carl writes that quote barter Romo had
once been a widely respected
trailblazing Financial journalist ah
here's the things I said she was the
first television reporter to report live
from the floor of the New York Stock
Exchange now she had her own show on Fox
News and she was using it to boost a
series of unfounded allegations designed
to overturn a presidential election as
president Donald Trump frequently
praised her granted her interviews
um okay on Sunday November 8th one day
after Fox and all the major networks
said Joe Biden was president-elect
Bartiromo used her Sunday show on the
network to highlight the most outlandish
allegations of election fraud through an
interview with Sydney Powell remember
Sydney Powell that completely cuckoo for
Coco Puffs attorney Powell delivered a A
fever's rant Carl wrote and Bartiromo
didn't expect Express one ounce of
skepticism it was all a lie he wrote but
Sydney Powell's deranged theories would
have never taken hold if there weren't
people in positions of power and
influence who had promoted them people
like Maria Bartiromo Bartiromo comes up
several times in betrayal in
mid-november according to the book
Bartiromo called Barr to complain that
the doj hadn't done anything to stop the
Democrats from stealing the election
listen to this she called me up and she
was screaming Barr told Carl on the
record I yelled back at her she's lost
it
imagine the gall of calling up the
attorney general and saying you're not
doing anything to stop this voter fraud
which doesn't exist of course
um Carl said he reached out to Bartiromo
for a response because after all it's
highly inappropriate for a journalist to
call the attorney general and demand he
do something related to a criminal
investigation barter Romo did not
respond but a Fox News spokesperson did
get back to me and denied Barr's account
of the conversation on barter Romo's
behalf through this the fox spokesperson
Bartiromo claimed Barr was the
aggressive one yelling and cursing
during the call well he'd be justified
in doing so if Maria Bartiromo is
calling you up and saying what the hell
are you doing Fox reiterated the same
statement in a response to a CNN
business inquiry on Sunday
later in the book Carl described
bartiromo's program as a shortcut to
Trump saying that Powell had a reliable
platform that ensured she could speak
directly to the president Powell's
interviews with barter Romo caught
Trump's attention and gave her a direct
line to the White House what an insane
situation that Trump White House was in
those last few months like it was a
crazy Administration throughout but in
particular once the election took place
and once it became clear that Joe Biden
was going to be the next president all
the stops were pulled out all all hell
broke loose Trump having off the Record
meetings specifically to circumvent
presidential records rules Fox reporters
calling up the attorney general and
demanding that they investigate
something that a reporter thinks they
can tell the Attorney General to do
lawyers like Sydney Powell using the
media to try to speak to Donald Trump
because Donald Trump is known to watch
TV all day every day just just a
complete uh um it's almost like a
childish Romper Room of sorts it's hard
to even know how to describe it and of
course wrapped up in all of this
are all sorts of possible potential
crimes uh many of which are being
investigated in Georgia by the southern
district of New York maybe at the
federal level and hopefully we'll find
out even 10 of it I continue to think
that actually the further we get from
the Trump presidency uh the more a lot
of this stuff is going to be buried and
we're never really going to know the
full scope of it
one of our sponsors is Shaker and Spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
that delivers ingredients and recipes
for Artisan cocktails right to you I've
been having fun using Shaker and Spoon
to make cocktails at home one of my
favorite is Citrus paradisi great blend
of vodka tonic lime green tea and rose
rose you open up the box the whole
presentation is awesome they've got all
the ingredients except the alcohol and
really easy instructions even if you
know nothing about mixing drinks like me
you're still going to have fun and
create drinks that turn out really well
I've been impressed with the results
I've gotten with the Shaker and Spoon
recipes you'll learn a lot about mixing
drinks it's fun to do on a date night
it's a great time and it makes a perfect
gift because you're giving someone a
really cool experience Shaker and Spoon
is giving you twenty dollars off when
you use promo code Pacman at checkout go
to
shakerandspoon.com Pacman and the link
is down below